In a galaxy's cloud, on cosmic paths we'll trace over wings.
Liberty is such a wondrous thing.
Behind us all, come see, come take your place.
We're leaving soon for...
There isn't anything for you to take care of.
I've received instructions that our spaceship is aboard the Cosmopolitan now.
That's great.
That means your trip home to Omega will be a pleasure cruise, I'm glad.
Yeah, guess so.
But I sure was hoping we'd get a chance to see lots of things first.
The submarine cities, for instance.
Well, that'll be an excellent reason to come back and see us again.
You sure are lucky that you can stay, you and Psyche, but I admit I'm a little jealous.
If Psyche had been well enough to travel, we'd have gone back with you.
In any case, we'll go back on the new ship.
Bye. Thanks a lot.
Passengers for Port Doppler. Immediate departure.
And Metro, you take good care of him.
It's mainly for producing plankton.
It took man an incredibly long time to realize that one kilogram of tuna fish required ten kilograms of sardines.
10 kilograms of sardines required 100 kilograms of animal plankton,
which in turn required 1,000 of vegetable plankton.
In hard times, a food shortage better 1,000 kilograms of protean.
Just one.
I think that that was obvious.
Those are some of the ancient offshore drilling platforms abandoned for centuries.
The oil has long since used up anyway.
What would we do with oil today, huh?
You see the stations for thermic energy from the sea.
Thermic energy?
Yeah, that's right.
Now there's a difference of some 20 degrees for each 1,000 meters of depth.
thermic reaction produces electricity of course it's an archaic system been abandoned a long time
now there's lots of plant plankton over there and over there there's animal plankton hey could
we go see the whales now oh plant is what they really like to eat hey they may come to the
surface well with whales they think everyone is jonah fantastic i've been lots of places
in the universe but i never saw an animal that size tell me are there many of these characters
around oh yeah thousands in a way you could say whales are our model farms protean reserves you
can imagine how well we take care of them they're well protected in complete freedom there's some
more over there fabulous really fantastic they seem to be playing they're playing oh you know i
could watch them for hours but right now we better not get involved in that game or we'll end up the
ball picture is part of the poseidia complex one of the old underwater cities i told you about it's
Easier getting there through tunnels in the seabed, but since we're here now, well, hey, go and take a look.
All the room anybody could want.
Hotels, private apartments, hospitals, everything.
What you see here above the surface is only a tiny part of the hole, mostly underwater.
One section of this for centuries now, people on Earth have felt when the sea, cultivate it, exploit it, live in it, have fun in it.
You know, it's just like being out in space.
Yes, you're quite right there.
Consider, apart from outer space, the sea was man's last great adventure.
his pioneering spirit could again have free reign for a while what's all this abandoned
factories centuries ago crude oil was refined here natural gas coal all of it taken from the
sea we still process protean down here little processors cobalt uranium nickel copper many
others all from the sea hey come along come on come on in the sea like all the rest come along
pierrot don't want to be late huh gold gold nuggets pretty interesting all the same not worth
much now? Used to be. We can synthesize it now all we want. Remarkable when you think
about it. Only you know there's a curious thing. For some time now a quantity has drastically
declined. The days that it had been expected to be very rich and metals have been found
so poor it almost looks like it's stolen. What's stolen? Another C. A surprising idea
I admit. But my friend, he'll tell you more about that once you meet him. Did I tell you
a captain he is in the underwater police? Young fellow of remarkable qualities. You'll
see. Lately, his shoulder's been bothering him. Doctor doesn't know why. Anyhow, you two get on.
Sphere goes down. The pressure inside rises to equal the pressure. The water, it's all automatic.
Where in the world is that, fella? Is this inquiry into the missing nodules? Well, the important
thing is that you got here. I'd like you to meet Lieutenant Piero of Omega. It's an honor and a
privilege to meet the man who saved the earth. How do you do, Lieutenant? Yes, well, Piero, this is
Captain Euphonos. Speak to his friends, one of our best specialists in underwater problems.
I think he's more at home in the sea than on the land.
Maybe you're part fish, Captain.
Oh, your shoulder still hurts you.
Well, it should go away in time.
And speaking of time, we're late for lunch, and I for one am starving.
Lunch at the bottom of the sea. You like it?
It must be as fascinating to move in as space is in other worlds.
No, you realize the pressure here is three tons per square centimeter.
Three tons per square centimeter is enormous.
We're at 7,000 meters.
No man could swim this deep without equipment.
How deep do you go when you're out for a swim?
Oh, 150, 200, perhaps.
That's good.
And consider, most individuals, even in good physical condition, lose their judgment at less than 100 meters.
Yes, it's called Rapture of the Deep. You've heard of it, I know.
Yes, of course. How do you manage? Is it training?
No, our friend is a special case. I'm convinced that he's from Atlantis.
No, in fact, I'm from the Canary Islands, which now allows our venerable friend to expound all his fanciful theories concerning Atlantis.
No, you can say what you like. My opinion is unshakable.
You'll never change it any more than my opinion that the metal thieves are among your friends.
I'll get you into the police force yet.
I'd like to dive with you one day, Pete. Could we arrange it?
Of course, Lieutenant. It's easily arranged.
We could do a little underwater archaeology.
I think you'd like that.
Are you sure you won't come along?
No, I can see myself all dressed up like a funny fish.
No, my beard would create so much drag I'd end up going backward.
You won't have to go through decompression training, or CO2 tolerance, or nitrogen narcosis tests.
You did all that as part of your space cadet training.
We won't go too deep.
If we get separated, do not dive below 80 meters.
Otherwise, there's the danger of rapture of the deep.
And take three stages for decompression, very slowly, as you rise toward the surface.
This is plant plankton, the basis of all our aquaculture, and of all our animal plankton, and hence of our fish stocks.
In addition, the photosynthesis it carries out cleans the Earth's atmosphere, absorbing carbon dioxide and releasing oxygen.
Me inside at all times.
Giant squid, he won't hurt us.
Come closer.
Take a look.
He's harmless.
Sunken city.
Am I dreaming?
They're calling to me.
Be well.
Captain hadn't found you when he did.
Might have torn off your oxygen mask and your delirium and ended up fish food.
It's a lucky thing that the captain is the best in the business.
You were a goner.
A lucky man.
to him, but it was extraordinary.
It had a kind of reality.
Really, at the time, it wasn't like a dream.
Yeah, yes, it's very subtle, I know, I know.
But that young captain, how did he manage to find you
at the right place at the right time?
Telepathy? Who can say?
Yes, who can say, as you say.
Well, anyway, I'm going to ask him.
It's a real mystery, you know.
He should be here any minute now,
unless, of course, he's late as usual, on time.
You feeling all right now, Lieutenant?
Back in shape?
Pete, I'd like to introduce you to...
to Lieutenant Mercedes.
Psychi to her friends.
Why?
Is it?
Well...
You know, Captain, I have the feeling we have already met.
Is that what you're feeling?
Yes, it's true. I know you.
Strain, come to me out of a dream.
Did we know each other in another life?
Yes, that's what I think.
In another life.
Now I have three convalescents here.
If you don't mind my saying so.
In my day, we were made of sterner stuff.
Please, try to remember I must know.
Where did we know each other and at what time?
Please, very important that I know.
I saw you.
It was in a boat. The world was crumbling around us.
Yes, that's right.
And in front of us, Poseidon is sinking into oblivion.
Poseidon is capital of Atlantis.
And Poseidia, our city today, built just where the other had sunk.
That's why I came here. I had to confront my fantasies.
Dreams are reality.
And I was right.
In the water, I can no longer distinguish reality and fantasy.
I see certain places.
That's just what I saw when I was down there.
What do we know of our dreams? Are they not premonitions of things to come, or memories of our ancient past?
I know I can tell you what is in my heart. Please let me try.
The first Atlantids, from far away, came to the Earth over a million years ago.
They were beings perfect in every way, pure in heart.
They took on human form, probably in deference to the Australopithecus, those evolved monkeys that peopled the Earth at that time.
Far from their own planet, they grew bored.
Nevertheless, they helped the Australopithecus to evolve into Homo sapiens.
They used to play all sorts of games.
This did not please those who had sent them.
The Atlantis were sent home and were punished, all of them.
My memory of that period is confused.
I know that they came back later.
Their presence accounts for the lapse of five million years
between the disappearance of the Neanderthal and the appearance of the Cro-Magnon.
Even the ancient Egyptian priests speak of their return tens of millennia in the past that distant time.
I studied Egyptian mythology and I was astounded.
I knew what I was going to find there before I looked at it.
Somehow I had already lived it.
Plato also talks about Atlantis.
On Gibraltar, there is a marvelous land greater than Libya and Asia.
Soldiers grow lax with inaction.
One gesture, we are off to new conquests, new realms to the greater glory of Atlantis.
Wisdom and harmony have always been the guides of our people.
Little we have sought of violence and conquest.
Do our soldiers so lack the means to achieve happiness?
The greatest conquest for Atlantis, is it not each citizen's virtue?
Our men stifle beneath their mantle of virtue and boredom.
Friendship, wisdom, have always guided our men.
They are the treasures of Atlantis.
Esi, watch what you say, lest you trouble our harmony.
You high priest, you watch, lest in your concern over the enemy at the gates
you are pounced upon by the beast within.
My men grow restless.
Our violence, you understand.
Then go, my dear brother. May you learn on your way an important lesson.
The greatness of Atlantis rests on justice more than vainglorious dreams of conquest.
Moderation.
Moderation in all things.
Stride as giants.
Moderation. You shall have proof of all moderation.
Going to war. I want to go with them.
You are only 14, huh?
In my eyes, you are still my little boy, and I oppose all of this useless fighting.
Our victorious army has conquered all the lands surrounding the Mediterranean Sea.
Soon it will be the turn of the Greeks, then Egypt.
Our army, it is truly the army of Atlantis when their boats assail heaven with greater noise than their exploits.
You were weak, O seer. You are not equal to your task.
Is this the true and pure light of Atlantis?
Are we not the chosen ones ordained to nurture civilization and make it flower on this world?
It is now late in time. Great calamity will soon befall us. The end of our world is near.
Duty is to recall the army to Atlantis, oh sire.
Otherwise our revered ancestors on high will wreak destruction upon us.
Sire!
Well, we depart from this city.
We can no longer abide what is happening here.
At least you, faithful friend, you do not abandon me.
I leave you, sire.
Soon it will be done.
It is time now to prepare the people for their fate.
Father, if this war is not right, why do you not order your brother to return?
Think he would obey even if I ordered him?
He has always been troubled because he is not king here.
There, leading his army, there he is king.
There he can brandish his sword as if in power.
Is the welfare of two brothers equal to that of the whole people?
Ah, my son, you speak wisdom.
But some men are destined to guide the people,
and I still believe I am a more just ruler than he would be.
Yet, without the power to enforce wisdom, wisdom itself is nothing.
It is what my father said 9,560 years before our era.
Then one day news reached us. Our army was in retreat, fleeing before the Greek army.
Voracious is the appetite of the conqueror, insatiable, beyond measure infinite.
Uncle Essie returned, bitter. The people had not supported him as he had wished.
He sacked and ravaged all in his path.
You must speak with Essie. It is the only way to prevent catastrophe.
Should I meet with misfortune, you will care for your mother and our people, grace of the gods.
Metal has the right to set his face against destiny.
They murdered the king.
There's blood calls to me.
I must go, mother.
That is the price of honor.
It is a heavy price to pay.
Go, my son.
What good will it do you to go?
Because the end is already etched in time.
And we'll live for as long as we do.
Land as quickly as you can.
It's your only hope.
Wise men were to escape.
They had refused evil.
Even now be living in the sea.
Baby is born and baby can live in that warm water just as he had within his mother.
It is perhaps their descendants that Pierrot and I saw dancing.
to communicate with those others up there i believe that one day out of the sea will emerge
a great silver arrow that will streak into the sky in a symphony of primeval song and that day
the survivors of atlantis will be freed from their watery purgatory and will return again
to their home in the universe you're the so wandering come take your place we're